At the World Economic Forum on East
Asia in Vietnam, we are setting up a Davos
Debates video corner. Here, participants including
presidents and business leaders will respond
via video to your questions and ideas on the
region's future.
The meeting is under the theme: Rethinking
Asia's Leadership Agenda. The key question
we want to discuss with you is: "How can Asia
lead the world?" The 19th World Economic Forum
on East Asia will explore the many facets
of the region's rising influence.
What questions do you have for the leaders
who will gather in Ho Chi Minh City from 6-7
June 2010? Send your ideas and questions via
video or text to YouTube.com/Davos.
You can also vote on your favourite contributions
from others.
The contributions with the highest number
of votes will be put to the leaders at the
Davos Debates corner giving direct access
to some of the most powerful and influential
people in the world. The best entries may
also be shown at the meeting.
Tell us what you think.
Go to YouTube.com/Davos to join the conversation.